amazing thing happening in china where
the chinese government using cove as a
pretext has cracked down in ways they're
totalitarian even by their standards
locking the entire city of shanghai in
its homes ripping children from their
parents arms sending people to
concentration camps it's horrifying but
what's even more horrifying is how our
public health authorities the united
states have responded
with praise oh we could learn something
from the chinese
so watching that you begin to ask
yourself what could stop something like
that from happening here if the people
in our country are for it
well lily tang has been asking that
question she was born in china she came
to the united states to new hampshire
she's now running for congress
here's your campaign ad
i was born in china to illiterate
working class parents suffered under
mouths cultural revolution and communist
dictatorship i wanted freedom america
was my promised land people are losing
their rights to make a living and to
make their own life choices
are you worried yet
i am
i fear that the country i love is
becoming like the country i left
lily tang williams is a republican
candidate for congress in the state of
new hampshire and we are honored to have
us join us her join us now later
williams thanks so much for coming on so
that's a that's a wonderful ad that you
cut it sounds like your childhood in a
repressive country
really informs how you view america
right now what did it teach you
well i come america for
freedom and prosperity live my american
dream
i'm just worried that the this american
dream would not be there for my children
who were born in this country i have
been here for 34 years i have seen now
the country it's probably the worst
situation today than never been and i
see this rise of also terrorism and
cheerleading our country and cancelling
people's rights and
you know
silence decent voices and then what
we're doing to our school children kind
of remind me what i sing in china you
know i don't want another cultural
revolution happening
in my new country
no that's right and you fled the chinese
government now you see our leaders
making excuses the chinese government
praising the chinese government does
that make you uncomfortable
not just uncountable i'm terrified and i
have seen that the governments are
taking almost like tactics and even
terms from their playbooks
and our own country is so divided by the
traditional mouse tactic
identity politics and separate people
into oppressor versus the press and so
he used that technique to do his
cultural revolution i'm just warning
people we don't want that cultural
revolution happening here to destroy
this new country i love
ah are voters in new hampshire
responding to that message
yes we have lots of
people here that's why i come here
because i love that model live free or
die
and we also have lots of people like me
who love freedom and appreciate liberty
coming here through the free state
project so i wanted people to know what
i'm doing here so more people like me
will come here
yes and not just people from boston
turning into massachusetts north lily
tang williams you don't need to respond
to that but i feel it strongly anyway
great to see you tonight thank you so
much good luck
thank you for having me
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight